what kind of bride is Elle gonna be oh
my god drunk one
I thought the proposal on Instagram on a
boat how romantic
are you kidding I felt like if I ever
really like got like engage I thought
I'd be like I dare you to marry me and
something like dumpster whatever but
like I'm my fiance a sailboat under the
golden a rich beautiful sonic did you
sense it was coming at all did you have
any clue well the morning of you ad he
was like I thought he's Scottish the
faux pas go out and get something and I
was like what he gonna going again and I
was like oh my god it's gonna propose
today and it cuz I was like a brown
paper bags like no he's not and so I was
surprised and it was beautiful and
everyone's you know our whole family
it's you know so happy for us so it's
beautiful I know you're super close with
your stepdad and your mom and they're
both here and they look amazing
do the ask uh permission or anything
like that or Griffin his after I told
him that he had to but it was just a
really beautiful moment and it just
happened
um and so my except Deb was cool uh but
you know they've made up for it and
everyone's just you know we're all one
big happy family now I have to ask you
you said you're already thinking about
family are you thinking about kids
alright I want like 19 kids I want a
family band I want an orchestra yeah we
both we both want a family so I'll
finish this this cycle of my record and
hopefully you know start start my
youngins my beautiful mother and my
perfect on today how did you know that L
was the girl for you I just opposed tape
my mail she told my favorite band is
that the O's my favorite bunch of it was
for just hello
I heard though that you did not ask the
parents permission no show I had a good
old looking to do when I'm invited it
seems your website oh right like they
both like me and I both like them so
good have you forgiven a mom he's so
lucky that I fell in love with him from
the beginning
he's just I don't know he's the most
endearing a he's just I think he's an
angel I still think he's unreal we
totally love and accept him yeah